I used to know a guy who 9/11 happened
and he wanted to walk from LA to New
York he was gonna carry the flag that
does a thing for America I was like when
you're gonna do it and he said next week
and I was like but you don't work out I
could do it I feel if I run a hundred
miles a day and I was like you don't run
any miles a day and he looked just like
Tom Cruise - which is he the best part
the night before he was eating Carl's
jr. and I was like hey you shouldn't eat
that if you're going to walk 3,000 miles
tomorrow he was like it's fine the next
day came and we were driving him to the
beach and he had his American flag and a
shirt that said freedom on it that he
drew at the where the 110 and the 10
connected he was like we don't have to
go all the way to the beach just drop me
off here and I said on the freeway I
[ __ ] pulled over he got out of my car
with his backpack full of waters and his
shirt that said freedom on and an
American flag and [ __ ] started
walking east and here's the part I was
saving he's Canadian he was like I got
to do this for the America the end of
the day he called me and he was like hey
dude went pretty well I was like where
are you and he said Arcadia two or three
days in he he found a bike and started
cycling and then the bike broke
obviously and then he started
hitchhiking and he hitchhiked and he got
to New York in two weeks it took him
[ __ ] two weeks and he hitchhiked and
he didn't he didn't run him out a
hundred miles a day here in the most he
ever ran was the first day he went there
Arcadia